helpsters our goal is to help heart
prepare to play t-ball now who's got an
idea
yeah if we're playing t-ball we need a
ball i have a ball ah okay so that's
done and i know how to catch but you do
not have a glove well then we will fix
that with job one
get a t-ball glove
in t-ball you have to hit a ball with a
bat i have a bat but i do not know how
to hit ah then we shall teach you we
certainly shall and that is job two
teach heart how to hit the t-ball
okay okay
oh um he say heart
yeah you see that door over there tell
me yeah would you mind closing that leaf
i will do this okay
okay
what's all this thing well heart seems a
little nervous about playing t-ball am i
right yeah i noticed that yeah so what i
was thinking is maybe we should surprise
heart at the game to show how much we
believe in heart a surprise job what a
wonderful idea thanks great but i'm not
gonna put it on the board okay because
it's a rye exactly buddy bud
okay break break i closed the door that
is fantastic heart and guess what we
have our plan
we've got the plan got the trend we
figured it out we've got the plan what
happens when we've got the plan
i'll go find a place to practice great
and i shall get to work on the secret
job
and uh heart
you and i will go get a glove by
visiting
[Music]
cody hart wonderful to see you both what
kind of glove can i get for you
i have several let me show you
over here
oh
hello which glove is the glove for me
hmm
well let's make a rule to help us choose
if the glove fits on your hand
then it's the glove for you how about
this one
[Music]
no too smart man
it is not the glove for you
last one
it fits
get a t-ball glove
check thanks so much
thank you
heart i have set up the t-ball tea just
for you you do not know what to do now
oh well why don't we go through the
sequence huh yes please take it away
scattered okay
first put both hands on the back
[Music]
next swing the bat away from the ball
laughs swing the bat toward the bar
i did not hit it
hmm
um i wonder if there's something wrong
with the sequence well let's go through
it slowly okay okay first put both hands
on the back okay looking good
next swing the bat away from the ball
um
heart you're not looking at the ball
after you swing the bat away from the
ball then
look at the ball
ass swing the back toward the ball um
i hit them on yeah
[Music]
teach heart how to hit a t-ball
check
let's get you to the game all right
great news tony we have your t-ball
player
[Music]
[Applause]
it is me great news everybody we have
enough players to play oh watch it
looks like you're first
yeah
here's your back thank you you got this
heart we're gonna go find some seats
okay
where is mr prim with a secret job
right here
great
[Music]
that means that they love me
[Music]
surprise heart at the game
check thank you my friends we believe in
you remember the sequence
first put both hands on the bat
next swing the bat away from the ball
then look at the ball
last swing me back towards the ball
[Music]
[Applause]
helpsters
[Music]